je suis dit je vais demander le cva à
tous les chroniqueurs caroline ithurbide
quel âge et votre cv également alors
vous avez faim de ss en communication
ouais ouais ça paraît la meuf diaries
vraiment qu'elle en entretien et le
monde je vous le dis et alors vous aimez
vos bio gaz boxe thaï gymnastique niveau
compétition en italie
bref plastique fait quoi battant c'était
un truc c'était quand j'étais plus jeune
les hommes et genest et poutres autre
poutre
jean michel maire il a entendu le mot
poutre on dirait qu'on appelait la meuf
à la paix j'ai peine à [ __ ] attention
et avec la menacera green s'est levé le
gars il a levé la dresser les oreilles
allez jean michel maire tient jean
michel maire alors il a obtenu un bac b
pour les jeunes le bac il a eu service
militaire vous avez fait votre service
en 1980 vous étiez avec georges corm un
souk les monsois de commerce vous avez
fait une maîtrise en communication et
journalisme et ouais après journalistes
à l'est républicain fait l'hiver ouais
ouais ouais
grégory vers la flandre à quoi faire et
grégory que c'est un très grand reporter
à france soir chef sur un service chef
du service radio télévision figaro
jusqu'en 2010 et chroniqueur et ensuite
vous êtes chamois d'heure
parce que diverses et diverses
brulotte chamois d'or c'est le fromage
ski en ski d'accord brevet de secouriste
et 23 série hbo tient marié 51 ans
oui j'ai dit 54 ans vous donne les
agents soient mieux merci obtention d'un
bac à un pareil c'était elle a
maintenant mcphee lowey a duré très
longtemps cela n'existe plus et alors je
vais vous lire eh les mecs la tristesse
des hobbies qua non la tristesse des
hobbies de tearing antiquités legasse à
dire tu as envie de te plains élections
kilea cv normalement c'est un candidat
les sujets délicats ces mecs comme ça
allez j'y perds des 50 ans aussi ouais
c'est gentil ça dira sets de table ne
trouvez pas ça bon c'est dégueulasse
j'ai eu tous les compliments g carolyn
emery même j'ai même choisi avec mathieu
we made by c'est bien foutu de vaudieu
tu connais comme ça jusqu'au mont va
bien boutonnée jusqu'au vous êtes bien
dégueulasse comme isner en 83 il a été
finaliste de mister camping sauvage
il a été finaliste le gaz ne s'est pas
de formation avec eux vous avez fait
j'ai été battu de justesse
bah oui oui avec du camping sauvage et
on était une bonne quinzaine quand même
ça il ya eu un vote et j'ai perdu je
m'en veux encore
j'aurais dû gagner ah oui très bien me
va très bien vous êtes alors est quand
même il a été journaliste et rédacteur
en chef du parisien journaliste l'équipe
chroniqueur radio directeur adjoint de
la rédaction de france soir
professeur de journalisme à l'oeil j
paris et chroniqueur attitré pas de
chaque fois c'est ça fait marrer alors
question mais vie fatou bâ mélanie la
télévision au sénégal
los angeles londres et du tout rêver
tout un shakespeare le football le ski
de fond l'amour la marche rapide le
cinéma à la séance de 9 heures aux
halles
et gilles verdez co vous faites la
marche rapide
ah oui c'est ma spécialité des vagues
qui m'a
c'est max mara je suis amer à une souris
dans les halls s'il fait un peu un beau
déhanché west ham est abonnée au chili
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]